un ataque ruso esta vez en kramators una
víctima mortal y tres personas heridas
fue el saldo que dejó el misil que
impactó la ciudad de ucraniana este
martes en el don vast ambas partes
luchan en la que es considerada la
batalla de Infantería más Sangrienta
desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial el
presidente voló de mirt selensky acordó
con su Comando militar continuar con la
defensa de la ciudad de Back
nació sku hoy estuve en contacto con
nuestros comandantes es muy duro el este
muy doloroso debemos destruir el poder
militar del enemigo en vilojorisca
marinca abizca y bakmuth Bulevar y todos
los de mal lugares donde ahora se está
luchando por nuestro futuro el de todos
los ucranianos en
Moscú el portavoz del kremlin Dimitri
prescott expresó el desconocimiento del
gobierno a la jurisdicción de la Corte
Penal Internacional después de que
reporte se indicaran que las primeras
órdenes de arresto contra individuos
rusos por crímenes de guerra serían
emitidas Próximamente Este martes
Vladimir Putin defendió la resiliencia
de la economía rusa y reiteró que el
país lucha por la existencia misma del
Estado ruso muy rara hemos multiplicado
nuestra soberanía económica después de
todo con qué contaba nuestro enemigo con
que nos derrumbaríamos en dos o tres
semanas o en un mes con eso contaban
pero no fue así resultó para muchos de
nosotros y aún más para los países
occidentales que las bases fundamentales
de la estabilidad rusa son mucho más
fuertes de lo que nadie pensaba
desde el kremlin aseguran que una
eventual resolución pacífica al
conflicto vendría con condiciones para
ello Ucrania tendría que aceptar lo que
Rusia califica como nuevas realidades
haciendo referencia a los territorios
ilegalmente anexados y que controla
parcialmente